[Music]
but first thousands of supporters of
pakistan's former prime minister imran
khan are gathering in the city of lahore
they're expecting to hold a mass protest
in the coming hours khan is pushing for
a return to power after losing a
no-confidence vote in april kamal haider
is joining us live from lahore so what
is the significance of the rally taking
place today
is hugely significant given the fact
that imran khan's government was thrown
out
through a word of no confidence not just
in islamabad but here in the punjab
province also
however there was a run-off election
his party is now back in power
and this is of course his first major
rally
in the provincial capital
of the province now it is also
significant because pakistan is
celebrating
its 75th independence day tomorrow
and this is the eve of
pakistan's independence which is also
pakistan's diamond jubilee so indeed he
wants to send a message
and he of course will be announcing his
next line of action because he and his
supporters have been demanding an early
election saying that the country needs a
fresh mandate and without that the
country cannot come out of the huge
economic crisis that pakistan is
confronted with okay thank you so much
kamal haider reporting for us from
lahore